the one country  that the world uses  the the five letter word dream with you  know we don't use the dream world with  any country the only one we've ever used  it with was america the american dream  why are they trying to change it well  remember there have been people who have  disputed the legitimacy of our  governmental system since the very  beginning  they said you can't have a country  that's run on the will of the people  you have to have a monarch  you have to have a ruling body  and  those kinds of ideals have been around  from the very beginning and they're  still there  and there are those who believe that the  ruling class knows better than the  people  and  it's really for the good of the people  that you empower those people and that  they need to do whatever they have to do  in order to gain the power  in order to do quote good for the people  unquote